all right are we ready
okay
do you need a mic check or anything i
think i'm all set you don't need one um
all right ivan
yes sir ivan uh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
the foothills in the san gabriel valley
like pasadena area
and tell me about your family growing up
yes both mom and dad
uh
a nuclear family i guess
uh yeah there's
uh my pops
uh stan archie i call him
his name's stan i call him stan archie
and my mom i didn't i didn't get along
with her but
she's a very
i'm a very logical creature i don't have
as good of intuition and or instinct
i i operate more on reason and logic and
she's completely
that way so we just clashed but
you're closer to your dad
yeah way closer i my mom and i were just
my uncle told me um
i mean i wasn't mom's boy or dad's boy i
was grandma's boy if anything my
grandma's kind of raised me again after
they did after i went out in the world
and came back
uh but uh
at her 100th birthday party my uncle
told me a weird story he said i saw the
day that you got smarter than your mom i
don't know what that means but he said i
figured out because
she'd say no and i'd argue and then one
day i just said why and then that from
that day he said i had her she i always
got her upset
but that's why i always got you know
because i said so it wasn't a good
enough reason for anything how would you
how would you describe your childhood
it was good we lived in a pretty safe
mostly white suburb but it was still it
was like
middle class we were lower middle class
like
my pops i guess got a deal and a
mortgage and we had a house
so it looked nice you know two floors
and everything but we didn't have any
money
you know we
ate out of cans if we did and all that
you know pretty poor did your parents
stay together no
no um
when i was like 10
it went apart and
stayed with my pops and he like went to
school and
so we were latch key kids you know
how to get home from school nobody's
there
you know right
your dad was working yeah yeah
and uh how far did you go in school
how far did i go yeah
i got to high school
but um
halfway through 10th grade
i hated it but my pop said
i have to go you know this california he
said you have to go
or if you
drop out of school
you either have to get the proficiency
in california from here but there's a
proficiency exam it's like a state ged
i hear it's easier uh
so either get that or or get you know if
you want to live with me so i did so
like
i had to stay in school but i didn't do
anything or pay attention
you know but until the results got back
and it was just pass or fail so i don't
know how i did but
it's a long test you go take in covina
for all day you know and then
they tell you if you pass or fail and
and then you can
get out of school
so after school you did what
music
i played music i've been
in bands and
i
haven't made a full living i'm not a
rock star but i mean i've i have
released
independent you know i've released
albums i've toured all over the country
towards people like uh
chitanda underground you know legends
jaton damon from christian death i used
to tour with her um and that was a band
uh
called tongue has a couple of records i
was
called 13 knots you know death rock punk
rock oh
not commercial stuff you know music has
been your life
yeah
pretty much
the whole ride right
yeah i started playing when i was 11 or
12 or something
that's all i all i paid attention to
that a little bit of art but i didn't
work as hard as music
what does music do for you
what does it do for me stabilizing does
it keep you on track does it yeah it
does
not everything but almost everything for
me i mean
you know you're taught you're telling me
like emotionally or psychologically or
something like that right psychology
yeah yeah yeah it's dangerous art art
you know aristotle i read i read i you
know used to read a lot too but
aristotle's like there's life unexamined
is not worth living well
an examining mine a life without some
kind of art or something is wouldn't be
worth it to me you know um
i
so
i haven't made a liv like a living off
and i've been able to buy a house or
anything like that but i mean i'm
definitely a professional musician i've
been paid but
it's uh
got to express myself i guess
you know creativity is a very i'm driven
to you know maybe um
i mean i'm definitely
was
ocd when i was a kid you know
any form of creativity i think is very
stabilizing
uh
yeah it gives you something to focus on
i mean
man my life's almost aimless like it is
but it would be
i guess completely aimless without
you know music and playing playing
guitar it's mainly what i do i can play
drums and bass and stuff but
uh
i've told him capable
or above above that you know
you've had relationships you've been
married
uh well for a second when i was
when i was a when i was a teenager or 19
or 20 or something and
a girl
came at me uh with with logic and reason
and asked me convinced me long story she
was like uh
oh could you be with one person the rest
of your life i go you know i don't know
you know variety i can't say when we're
there because variety i'm a big
believer of variety is a spice of life
and she's like well what if that person
you know changed you know they they
could look inactive or whatever you know
she just used logic and and i with logic
i couldn't refute it but i thought
when i was a teenager
what the hell out i'll uh
i'm immortal or you know invincible i'll
i'll get into it i can get out of it i
get out of everything else
i used to do ridiculous stuff socially
when i was a kid and i never i survived
i lived through everything
but uh so
that for just a couple years you know
but
and no kids just experiment what's up no
kids no
what's what's been the your
favorite memory from your life how old
are
ages is a number
how many times you've been around your
local star
right
circumnavigated what's been your
favorite memory of your life oh man your
favorite time of your life
well
i'll try to give you something but
my grandma as i said i i would be more
of a grandma's boy than mom or dad's uh
my gramps was a writer and she was from
new england and she was really she was
killer and she
we just got along we dug each other um i
lived with her for a lot of years and
took care of her toe she uh in the last
five years of her life she you know can
walk and stuff but um
she when i one time once when i asked
her what her favorite
something was she said
uh why should i pick a favorite i can
have them all you know like a favorite
color i can have them all so i you know
she didn't i don't there's not really a
point necessarily a favorite but uh
some of my favorite
oh
yeah i don't know um
i don't yeah like i don't think it turns
my life coming to a head that way but
but i i did enjoy a lot of
the tours that we did certain gigs we
played with tsol once and
my amp went out and
ron emery who's the guitar player
i went out i went to his bus and knocked
and asked if he had any tools i could
use and he goes what's the matter and i
said my amp's broken and we were about
to open for ts well huge band if you
you know
punk rock band and he goes
stay there he came with the toolbox
didn't hand it to me he said let's go he
went with me he fixed my amp so he could
open for him that night and then
dedicated a song to me he was like the
song's for
ivan
because i asked him if they were going
to play it silent scream school song but
he dedicated to me as killer
uh that was a that was a cool memory
um
you know
dez kadenia from black flag was on a
record
that was
that was a cool thing i mean
i don't want to drop names it's yeah
it's uh right no it's kind of tacky but
i'm just saying meeting people that i
grew up listening to the reason that i
play was you know and being friends with
him is a really cool thing yeah and
there's more than that you know but i'd
be name-dropping if i said it but what
what personality traits do you have to
help you survive help you get by in life
um
well i don't tell people this usually
this is a kind of secret um
i think but
see i'm not baptized in anything and and
i've
read all about all the religions eastern
western you know what makes sense most
to me is more philosophy it's uh the dow
beijing you know loud zoo
that makes more sense to me yin and yang
and and um
but my philosophy my personal philosophy
is uh believe it or not i have some
weird things you'll you'll hear this uh
but bugs bunny
bugs bunny is my icon because um
right everyone knows bugs bunny right
well think about it
when bugs bunny
when the hunter is going after him
or yosemite sam or whatever and they
shoot him and and he's like
worried about it ah
and when he gets scared or reacts and
overreacts to it
he gets [ __ ] up
he gets he loses when he's when he
worries about it and
and all that [ __ ] the monster the witch
whatever
but when he stops caring and he starts
dressing in drag and kissing them and
and running you know when he doesn't
care see bugs bunny doesn't give a [ __ ]
when he gives a [ __ ] he loses
but when he doesn't give a [ __ ] and like
i said gets kisses him gets in drag does
all that [ __ ] he wins and that's what
personality trait
i mean i do care about things of course
but yeah it's almost rolling with the
punches you gotta
like laugh at everything and uh
you know do the equivalent of putting on
drag and kissing and making you know
that let let them be fools and try not
to be one yeah that's it
don't take it so hard you know it's not
a dick and no one gets out alive
at the end
but uh stuff like that i guess because
it wouldn't help to uh oh man you know a
lot of [ __ ] up shits happen to me like
being a musician my guitars got ripped
off man that was [ __ ] up but
yeah
what are your
personality traits that are
the most destructive for you
hmm uh
i'm way
so much more of a thinker than a doer
the emphasis to do things
i don't
i don't yeah i don't hardly
like i said i i'll think and i'll spend
a whole day
drawing or writing and thinking and and
doing stuff in my head not really
solving problems but figuring things out
for myself but i won't do anything you
know
i won't go get food or you know
drugs when i get them or you know i mean
or even eat if it was there sometimes i
don't know i just you know
do you mind if i ask you take off the
glasses no
it was good anyway i forgot they were on
are
drugs a part of your life
uh
yeah now they are not not like they used
to be um
i was gonna tell you
i don't know how much longer you want
this to go but we can go half an hour
okay cool um
drugs
are
a weird thing i have some philosophies
about that too i philosophize a lot like
i said i don't do i don't go out and
make money i'm not a hustler go get her
like of that
uh
i'm definitely an anomaly you know
people tell me
like
not one of my friends doesn't say that
i'm unlike anyone else but it's not
always a good thing
you know i guess i'm
unique but oh it's not
not horrible to deny my why is this
supposed to be all candid i don't know
embarrassing myself probably anyway
people i know know it already uh
but
um
drugs
it was heroin is the main drug when i
was uh
when i was 15 years old i uh
um
right around that's the time i i lost my
virginity too right right after i turned
15 to 15 and and uh right that time i i
i'd never done any
drugs except
some weed and i hate and i don't like it
it just doesn't
makes me makes you complacent
and uh and as much as i
think but i think i
protested my head i know things you know
it makes me complacent
it makes me like laugh at [ __ ] that i
know is not funny and then i get angry
it's just weed doesn't agree with me so
i knew it wasn't that i don't count that
and um
uh
but i've dropped acid it was a the one
thing i you know the first time i did
drugs and and i decided for myself
so i would either
never do any drugs my whole life or if i
was going to bother you know it was all
that
egg in the frying pan you know like this
is your brain this is drugs you know
this is your brain on drugs any
questions i always on the commercial
immediately went yeah right here
uh
if i don't like my eggs raw why should
my brains be
but uh
when i was a kid i was saying it but um
it's uh
it's uh what was i saying oh that i
would either do that or i'd go to forget
gateways and all that [ __ ] i'd go do the
most taboo thing in the most taboo way
so that's like
before my teens were out
i shot heroin
so i just went straight to that i never
did coke or
you know
i never snore anything or smoked
anything nothing like that i did one
type acid then i shot heroin i've tried
everything since then
but um
getting old but uh but
the drug heroin addiction is a weird
thing because it is the most taboo you
know it's the opiates and even more than
the pills you know on the street and
even though it's a trade name which is
funny but
um it's like
every day
just when you survive and go through the
day it's like your superhero you do
heroic things to to get this drug that
nobody wants you to have in it everyone
can get busted and the liaisons are all
shady and you get hurt i've gotten
[ __ ] up and stabbed in my left you
know like a knife in my lip right there
and stitches
and
stuff like that uh but you're not a hero
to anyone but you but the stuff that you
do it's like a
you know a cat running through a
glass house of dogs and hammers coming
down or something like the weighted it's
a weird thing that you're a hero
and you're also
injecting it's like
you're a vampire you know you don't like
daylight and you got blood involved but
it's your own and you're taking it out
and putting it in
and uh
you get pale and thin and it's a it's a
weird it's a whole weird existence but i
i quit shooting up
a year
a little yeah like a year ago i don't do
that anymore but like i said i went i
went for the most taboos in the most
taboo way
um
but uh
it's uh
i don't do that anymore
terrible you know a lot of things come
with that i had
you know you could you get hepatitis you
get
uh abscesses you get all kinds of messed
up stuff
um i guess uh other people i i know one
or two of the people i don't know if
that's you know you're not supposed to
say but one of the people that did your
thing and i know they've had terrible
trouble with their health from that
stuff
but um
uh it inadvertently made me
an amputee oh wow right tell me about
that
i lost my thumb uh well
it was a weird thing like i said a
unique thing but it made sense to me it
was uh it happened to be in 2016
at the end almost so the beginning of
2017 is when i
got happy but what happened was
i uh
i had a
brand new brand new needles uh from from
you know they were they were brand new
from exchange and everything they
weren't used at all
so it wasn't dirty
it was anything like that but
i was uh
somehow holding it like this or
something like that like two knees or
something i reached for some water i
went to get it like that and bam it
punctured my thumb like all the way the
bone went straight and straight out you
couldn't even see it i had to wait for
one like dot of blood but it went deep
and it [ __ ] hurt
and it was just a dot and i was like
[ __ ] so i dumped peroxide on it and
everything like that but abandoned all
that i was supposed to do
and it
still got infected and blew up
but
i was in a crisis that year you know
you know that song bye bye american pie
that old song i guess that's supposed to
be about when like richie valens and
buddy holly and the
chantilly lace guy
that dj from texas died in a plane crash
and this must be the day the music died
like the worst that's supposed to be the
most tragic and uh i say
maybe whatever uh
i don't like the music that everyone
likes either i always thought a funny
joke was what would it take to reunite
the beatles three more bullets
before
before uh
the other guy died but uh the point
being that
um
in 2016 when when it happened um
january 10th two days after his birthday
he drops black star david bowie dies
all right
suddenly uh at the end of year i think
november or something like that prince
dies
what the [ __ ] in an elevator you know
with pills didn't know that he was into
anything i [ __ ] up his hips doing all
that he splits and [ __ ] all those years
and then and then also let's know but
pete burns from dead or alive you know
you spin me right round baby right
around that guy who's cool uh music he
died too
and i just thought to myself
wow that really pales as the worst you
know my friend called the worst rock and
roll yuri ever i usually use that term
but
i i thought i honestly thought
not that
i'm their caliber but i aspire to be you
know we stand on the
shoulders of giants type thing and i
thought a year that
david bowie and prince you know nor
prince nor pete burns could survive
i didn't see how anyone was gonna i
didn't i couldn't see how i was gonna
survive that year so i was just waiting
to die somehow
because i didn't see how i would survive
a year that they didn't and then a weird
thing i'm not a superstitious guy but it
made sense when that happened
my thumb and it started getting infected
and like i said on a brand new sterile
needle
that went straight and straight out and
it started getting infected
and i didn't go to the hospital right
away i got some antibiotics from my
friends and it started to get better and
then i but i ran out of them and it
started to get worse again
and i thought
okay this is how i'm gonna die
and
but then it didn't seem bad enough to
kill me
you know infection and uh and and so
i
something inside me like it's weird i
know but i thought
it's
like
a sacrifice to whatever the sonic gods
are
that that's what they wanted they wanted
a sacrifice
and i mean it's my right thumb and i'm
right-handed i play guitar it affects it
it looks like i dropped pics all the
time now i i just i don't know if i
could get some prosthetic like the black
sabbath guy or special made pics
but i can't
pick with the
you know circle a furiosity that i used
to
i still can't play a bit i tried playing
my fingers like jeff back i don't know a
lot of stuff but it's gotten harder but
it affected it you know i could see how
that it totally is it totally turned out
to be but that's what made sense to me
that
i think
you know
suspending disbelief i might have
survived that year only because i made a
sacrifice to the sonic gods but i
that's how i lost my
thumb
from because you know not from shooting
up but because i
did i wouldn't have been [ __ ] around
with a
syringe if i didn't i suppose that was
that a setback emotionally for you
emotionally yeah i mean just
as a musician i can see it
you know your ability to create and
perform
um
like give me an example of how i don't i
mean like if you're a guitar player
you lose part of your thumb then your
ability to
play your at your best is going to be
yeah it [ __ ] it it [ __ ] with me and
and i stress out about it but how would
it how would it affect me get depressed
because you're just not as good as you
want to be um no i don't i don't
i don't think i take things emotionally
unless i start with them emotionally you
know like if i was with some if i love
somebody
and then i get my heart broken you know
i i'm
i'm living with that emotion and that's
an emotional experience so so that
affects me emotionally but
but
i had never been emotionally attached to
my thumb so i don't think i got
emotional about it but yeah it
definitely you know
affects me it's [ __ ] up i don't you
know i don't know how to get you know
i've little things
that to compensate forever but i still
drop pics all the [ __ ] time
i can't
anchor it like i used to because
my thumb's missing so
they call me nine now
my initials are ix anyway the roman
numeral for it so
but uh
yeah
you're a non-conformist
am i what a non-conformist yeah
well
i don't know i'm it's not a good
good
policy to judge a book by its cover but
what would you say by looking at me i
would guess yes yeah i guess so
i am too but i look different than you
right right but um i mean
i don't know
how on purpose that is
like i don't
all right yeah i i do refuse to
cooperate with certain mores of society
like things oh cool things
i do you know i mean like
i just don't understand people i i've
always thought you know
people say like you've said well have
you ever heard
hey you look like when i was a kid it
was funny because my brother looked just
like alex
cooper he had long brown hair and brown
eyes and [ __ ] and i was supposed to
leave look like you know [ __ ] up with
eyes and i guess like resemble bowie but
um
that's what i've got my whole life
although a guy one time on a bus he's
like do you know what he looked exactly
like i was like yeah i uh but we write
he's like no he said jay aston from gene
loves jezebel i've never heard that one
that was a trip
but uh
i'd read red hair at the time but um
i uh
i uh i i i don't understand people's
motivations i don't understand what they
want and why they want it and
you know what they think and you know
what's so important to them i don't
you know i
i'm like a gypsy like django reinhardt
or something i don't
i don't want
a yacht or a house or like that stuff
wouldn't appeal to me sounds like which
responsibility that
what do i want it for if i unless i had
so much money that had people to take
care of all that [ __ ] because
i wouldn't
you know i i
i want a place to live which i don't
really have
homeless but uh i mean you know
equipment and a place to keep it
is like what i want yeah you know if i
have
a family a couple whatever i had kids i
guess i'd want i'd have to have a place
to keep them but i don't understand you
know that but so
and i don't conform i don't you know
think with somebody describe but i'm
certainly don't consciously decide to be
a non-conformist
no i think i think people either are or
are not yeah well
yeah yeah i just don't but it's well
like i think
a lot of standards i live by it's weird
but like um
think about it what's the last thing
what's the last thing that the coolest
guy in any room would say
what's the last [ __ ] thing that
they'd say
he the last thing he would say is that
he's cool
because if he had to tell you he
wouldn't be
so
you know someone who's
like
i'm a non-conformist and they wear a
t-shirt
i don't know maybe they're trying too
hard or something
it just would seem weird to me
but uh
you know i i don't i don't look for that
label or anything but uh yeah yeah i
suppose i am because i certainly don't
do things by the
other people's book or any anything like
that but yeah but what do you worry
about what are you afraid of
afraid i don't think i'm afraid of
anything
really uh
if but uh
if i was afraid of anything
it's funny that um
people
what i worry about let's go that first i
worry
about
uh surviving
because last you know for a while a
little bit here i've been surviving
rather than living and living is you
know can be
a good time but surviving is
not optimal you know but um
you know trying to get [ __ ] done and and
i feel like it's hard to get you know
leg up to try to trying to do that and
then this
this uh
coronavirus [ __ ] it was it was cool at
the beginning it got everything out of
the way and made it easier for people
you know like like for me i
i was staying in a studio it was a
stronghold you know didn't come in and
get out nope no corona got in there for
a long time but uh
now on the back end it's like they're
trying to get you tested and that shit's
no good for you and can't travel you
know publicly and
you know i mean and and
where to work the whole world is
changing you know
business isn't what it was the economy
is not what it was people
i got to figure out some
i gotta get a hustle you know something
online or something like that or that's
you know the future but
but what i scared of it's funny because
about the only thing i'm scared you know
people are scared like i don't know are
you religious you raised religious yeah
not baptized like i said me either but
um
kind of scared like people are scared if
there's not a heaven because
you know and and
they're worried about that or going
what what i'm kind of
what scares me is uh
is if there is
if they're
if there's a god
especially the christian one it sounds
like
it sounds like you have to participate
you have to like not sin
in order to go to heaven
or if you don't
you will go to whatever hell is
uh
and
i've read the bible it's not what you
know people walk around saying it is
like the devil is going to torture you
and [ __ ] he gets
thrown into the pit too you know he is
he's [ __ ] up too but
it the the thing that scares me is if
all that
duality if that when that [ __ ] was true
and you can't
opt out you can't decide not to
participate
like god's gonna make me
go go to
hell or heaven
and
and if you know
if i was gonna die
and i and i have to go to one i can't
just be over
like you know people say they want to
live forever well that'd be a drag
i mean you've seen it illustrated in in
like
vampire culture where you know
god does live for thousands of years the
same thing over and over and people that
they love live and die and they keep
going on and on and on i mean that [ __ ]
would get old besides the fact that
if you did live forever nothing's going
to keep you young you're going to
deteriorate
and at some point you know my grandma
i like to tell people it's funny i say
my grandma died suddenly out of nowhere
she's you know
i loved her a lot and she suddenly died
surprised at a hundred she surprised us
all came out of nowhere and people go oh
no i'm like
a hundred
it came out of nowhere they're not
getting the sarcasm
she had a good life what did she have
left to do you know
she knew what she was gonna do how much
you know stray cats how long like how
long you want to live anyway
and it's like
i mean i want to do [ __ ] and i want to
you know i want to accomplish stuff in
it but
getting old seems like more of a drag
than dying at a certain point like a
certain you know there's a hot dog bun
uh you know ratio that you how old
you're gonna get compared to how long
you're gonna live
i think that
living is gonna
outweigh it's gonna be a you know
death's not a burden it's a release
so but but if i had to play along it's
like you know i wasn't trying to trying
to go to heaven or trying to play those
games so if anything scared me that's
about the only thing like not afraid to
die it's just like what if i show up and
you know there is a god and he's like he
didn't play my game and and uh
entertain me or whatever he made you
know i mean that's what i always thought
why are there different colored peoples
the different pieces it's a complicated
game and only he knows the [ __ ] rules
but like it sounds like they're supposed
to battle each other
he made me he raided racism too but you
know i mean you didn't play and i'm like
well i didn't want to
i don't need to go to your heaven i
don't need to go to your house nope you
have to one of the other that that is
the only thing that scares me because
that would be forever this life
whenever it sucks
i've always said like one of my policies
is i don't hate i don't hate anybody
because that's letting somebody live
rent free in your head
somebody i hate live free in my head so
i don't bother he made this game
and and like
it's like you know a lot of people say
the culture has come to
you know let everybody you give out
participation ribbons for everyone just
for showing up no no winners and losers
it doesn't train people to
to uh
achieve to to you know to excel
if if like the guy that came in like you
know
i mean there's i'm not competitive or
sports i like basketball i mean just
that's all highlight reel the other ones
are kind of slow but um
i was one time i got clean i had nothing
to do and and and when i was young and
the bulls and you know the michael
jordan dynasty was going so i started
watching basketball and to my surprise i
became a basketball fan but anyway
um
i'm not like that but
but uh
you know there's something to be said
for for that as far as excelling
rewarding it you know but what's you
know what why why fight to get first
place if the guy got last place didn't
do anything he's gonna get around
essentially the same thing
um you know
you have to pose with him and all the
other ones the ones in between for a
picture in the paper or get a ribbon or
whatever but um it's like like there's
something to be said i don't advocate
but you know
uh you know second place is like
oh you know some getting some kid
you were second place oh good good son
that means you were the first loser
you only lost to one person and beat all
the rest but you were you were the you
know the first the number one loser but
uh
but
to
you know
in that way
the it's it
that that if if there was a god he's
gonna make you play no you have to you
didn't play this and you can't go down
so you have to go to hell and i'd have
to go to hell when i when i'm like
i don't know that
what are we going to do forever in
heaven
forever
i mean
they it you know it's supposed to be so
great you sit there with
you know when i write a lot of songs
about
that lyrics like stuff like you know
where do you go after you die to some
giant disneyland up in the sky where
everything is clean and perfect and
delicious and all day long you sit on
god's lap and make wishes
here's a coffin here's a hole where's
your body there's where's your soul
and like
you know i drew a picture of god today
but no one believed me i said just wait
and see stuff like that
but i think about that a lot but i mean
what if you know what if just imagine
that what if you showed up and
there was one and he was you know
whatever where he had a million eyes or
he was a guy
you know the
bathrobe with the beard like santa claus
or whatever the hell and he was like
you know you had you didn't play you
have to not repent you go here and it's
like okay but what really is going to
happen in heaven forever many mansions
blah blah you know i've read all about
that
uh
you know i the only
usually christians i've read more the
bible than they have apparently it seems
like i i mean the only one that is ready
you know as a pastor that i used to rent
a room from
he actually did but i'm just you know if
if he wouldn't let you
that that would scare me that i had to
pick one of the other because
like you know they
say i happen to be boring and hell's a
lot more interesting all your friends
will be there and [ __ ] well it's like
you know if you didn't want to
go to hell
then you you didn't want to go to heaven
either you know but he's going to make
you that would be that that's the only
thing that would scare me and it's it's
kind of weird because
but
i also understand you know better to
reign in hell than to serve in heaven
kind of thing i mean
i'm particularly prideful if
if there was a god
i i mean i would like to hang out with
the cat
you know even if i didn't want to do
things yeah
all right you know i just want a
permanent end you know to be over i was
in a coma once and it was all dark but
it was
it was a
calm and peaceful it seemed like it was
okay
you know nothing nothing was happening i
barely had any memory you know but i i
remember being conscious you know a
little bit but it was like dark i
couldn't see anything or feel anything
or hear anything but it was calm
peaceful and tranquil but i i'm thinking
you know okay could i just you know have
it all end and at that part but first
can i ask you
ten thousand questions
you know
i got it
i got i gotta complain some complaints
for you god you're gonna [ __ ] explain
some [ __ ]
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
most important thing i've learned in my
life
well
again
know one thing
everything things rely on themselves you
know there's a lot my like when my
grandma told me that and i was like in
my 20s it hit me hard about why i pick a
favor because
no one thing is important without the
other things for example people walk
around all the time saying they need
[ __ ] right i mean do you need anything
what do you need oxygen
what do you need oxygen for
tell me to breathe salute
okay but you can't prove to me why do
you need to live that's true
see people that people walk around need
need
don't there's only need if there is a
condition to be met or some caveat with
it you need
you know ice cream if you're having a
birthday party and you have cake and the
kids you know you need to breathe if you
need to lift yes in order to live you
need
a cheese you know to put between two
pieces of bread to make a cheese
sandwich yes with the for condition to
be met but
there's no such thing as need
really
you want it
and you want it for you know reason
maybe it's a good reason but
like i said without conditions because
i've no one could you know prove to me
that they're neat that anyone or
anything needs to live or needs to who
says why does it need to
and uh
so there's really no such thing as that
but we're all self-absorbed and
you know
self-important and
molecules aware of themselves and we
dominate the planet and
blah blah you know but
so you know what i mean stacked up so
anything whatever i did leave an
important i'll try and i'll try to say
something but it you know without all
the other [ __ ] it's it's not but
i'd say
some of the most important things that
i've learned
i don't know what the what that is but i
know i can i got a couple of mantras or
or like
you know i don't know if they're ethics
or codes or whatever to live by but i'll
just give you a rundown of the ones i
can think of right now and say these are
the things that
i try to always adhere to and so they're
i guess important to me um
one is uh it's funny because it's from a
fictitious source but
you gotta know man's got to know his
limitations
you know that quote
who's it from i don't know dirty hairy
fictitious but
it's true
and uh
that's uh i don't care it's uh you know
you consider source i don't know who it
is but it's it's self-evident and it
stands you know and so and it's that's a
good thing you know you gotta know your
limitations what your strength is what
you wouldn't be good for you know
like i'm a musician i'm a great you know
good musician if modesty permits um you
know the devil went down to georgia or
do you want to california dun told you
once son of a [ __ ] i'm the best there's
ever been
no but i'm saying i'm good but but no
matter how good a musician nobody nobody
wants to hire me to play horn in their
band because i don't do that i wouldn't
it wouldn't be good that's limitation
you know
that's not what i do i play
a different instrument but um so that's
one um
uh keith richards uh the cost of an
education
you know
no point i was trying to spill milk
order whatever happens to you you get
[ __ ] over something like that
you make something out of you just
realize that's the cost of an education
whatever happened to you and try not to
be that whatever it is again that
foolish or that
i suspect you know whatever whatever led
you to that
trying to repeat it but that was the
cost of the education you know
and um
what else uh
i think uh
doing to others is fine um
me
i don't
you know i'm a weird person and i've
certainly been in cd you know
when you're around drug deaths and
junkies and i'm not just that i've been
all around all kinds of people people
that worked you know for the courts and
[ __ ] like that but but um
um
i don't steal
you know people do and
if i was gonna i think i'd do it from
the man or something but but my friends
i always tell them it's like
and i'm always vindicated like you know
you get suspected because you're there
and you know there's something missing
and i'm like
that's fine don't believe me you know
what i mean but you'll find out for
yourself whenever you find out
you know you find that thing or you find
out who took it it won't be me and it
never is and i'm always vindicated like
that i don't take
anything because with my friends i
always
figure
that
and even people you know you're cool if
i need something i'll just ask you
the worst you could say is no
but you know i'll try to tell you hey
man i need
this because i don't have it you know
and
it's required again like i said no need
but it's required for this you know i
i can't do this without this can i get
that and
you know more often than not you know
friends are cool they'll give me what
they can i don't
try to ask a lot or whatever but you
know i mean
like thanks for coming to pick me up you
know you didn't even have to do that but
if you didn't i would have walked here
or whatever you know i mean i so it's
that that's that's you know i don't do
that but
i'm pretty honest um
blunt actually do the thing but
uh
let's see what else is important i think
you know
there but by the you know the grace or
whatever could go you you know i mean
like
don't judge books by their covers you
don't know you know
who you're talking to or what you're i
mean uh uh
archimedes gets killed in the dust by
some roman soldier because he's drawing
math in the dirt the guy that you know
the eureka guy in the tub that learned
about displaced water and made the screw
made
irrigation and aqueducts and you know
made water you could raise it from one
place to another not just in a waterfall
that guy when he was old was doing
equations of sand and soldier comes up
and he's like
hey old man move it you know i respect
my authority and he's like wait wait
till i'm done with this
and he [ __ ] slammed him down and
rubbed out what he wrote
you know the [ __ ] he's talking about
he's just some old beggar or something
you know and diogenes another great he
lived with dogs and was naked and took a
[ __ ] in public and all this stuff but he
did that on purpose
to non-conform but to show people
you know what their life
and what they were thinking of you know
and what they thought was so important
wasn't
you know and he said
he said great things you know alexander
the great came and said found him and
said i heard the great diogenesis here
i've heard of you i wanted to meet him
and he was he went up and and walked up
to him like if you're you're down the
ground he walked up and he was stan he
came in in the sun and he says
he was not the king yet he was prince
but he says i just want to know it's an
honor to meet you is there anything that
the great alexander can do for diogenes
and diogenes said yeah the great
alexander could get out of my light
step aside he didn't ask him for nothing
he didn't care and he laughed
and he said
uh
he laughed at his soldiers and it's i
think it's apocryphal but supposedly he
said
he said uh if i were not alexander
i and i was someone else besides
alexander i would wish to be diogenes
and diogenes said yes if i were someone
besides diogenes i too would wish to be
iogenese and he laughed again didn't
kill him didn't [ __ ] with him he he
respected diogenes was uh was a [ __ ] and
and another one day when they had him
he said what should we do with you when
you die it was getting old and he said
okay well
could you throw me over the wall
you know um
uh my body out there uh you know just
throw it outside of the grease in a
dashies of uh
wherever that was i think it was in the
south or something like that or on the
archipelago where uh
you know sparta and stuff was i don't
know anyway it was like he said what uh
cenopy and he said what should we do
with your body he says well throw me
over the wall my body and and give me a
good sturdy stick to to fight off the
wolves and they were like
you'll be dead how are you going to
fight off the wolves and he goes oh yeah
aha so what the hell do i care what
happens to my body
he goes feed him you know i mean use it
for something
you know he was thinking and so i think
you always
always think and don't be complacent
about thinking now
i mean
let me tell you
i've learned what uh just as valuable
what i haven't learned
and applied
you know you gotta
you gotta get [ __ ] done you know i've
one of the presidents says [ __ ] like uh
i mean the president's full of things
like uh
like uh you know i mean success is
you know
two two part you know a one
small percentage
you know five percent inspiration five
percent creativity
five percent talent and uh
[ __ ]
uh
85 perspiration you know i mean like all
the dedication all determination [ __ ]
like that and abraham lincoln was like
you know i care not how many times
you've
fallen down i care me how many times you
got up or maybe those knicks whatever
you know president's full [ __ ] like that
and it's like
i uh
should be more of a hustler but i've
always i'm always in my head
thinking [ __ ] like this out
but um
as far as operating
you know do uh
i don't know mr t you know
uh stay in milk
don't do school
uh you know do your do your vegetables
and uh
eat eat your homework whatever
yeah stuff like that but uh right on all
right oh wait no no i know i know what
i'm glad i didn't think of it
my friend
alice told me um one of the main mantras
is uh
don't sweat the petty things pet the
sweaty things
nice that's uh that's one of the most
valuable things that i've ever learned
and i also like moliere's look at life
he said
we die only once and for such a long
time
all right ivan thank you so much for
talking right on very interesting oh
yeah you can edit this off but it's
funny
you don't need a skydive a parachute to
skydive you know that right you only
need a parachute to skydive twice
you